well we have a look now at the mood in
germany when it comes to the pandemic
pollster infrates dmap has just
published its latest ard deutschland
trend a monthly nationwide survey
the poll was taken before the latest
lockdown announcements now despite
general acceptance of the anti-pandemic
measures increasing numbers of germans
want to see an
easing of restrictions check it out 10
percent
say restrictions should be lifted
completely
53 percent want the curbs to be lifted
at least partially and only one-third of
germans say that they
don't want the restrictions to be lifted
at all
let's bring in dw political
correspondent nina haza so what kind of
easing do
of restrictions do germans want to see
the most nina
well the poll says that the priority for
german seems to be for non-essential
shops to open again
27 of those um polled say restrictions
should be lifted completely and
55 say that they should be opened at
least partially
and not even one in five of those polled
want shops to stay
shut and then the ranking goes as
follows restaurants then hotels schools
museums cinemas and so on and then gyms
but you have to keep in mind that for
all those sectors even those ranking a
bit lower
that two-thirds of germans want some
kind of opening to happen
and that of course explains the pressure
that the government is
under to strike that balance of keeping
the virus at bay
and the mutations of course and the
desire by so many in this country that
there need to be different solutions
than
simply extending the lockdown so to
massively step up testing and
vaccinations
both of which has of course been very
slow okay so uh meantime let's look at
infection rates and hospitalizations now
because they have varied widely in
different parts of germany most of those
polled
here are the figures most would prefer
to see
a regionalization of anti-coronavirus
measures
only 38 percent that the say that the
restriction should be consistent
everywhere in the country 58 prefer the
measures to be
regionally variable
so nina any indication that the
preferences expressed breakdown
along party lines for example you know
how is this looking
oh yes this was extremely clear in this
poll the polls always ask for party
affiliations
which party do you support and so we do
have a very clear picture
supporters of five out of the seven
parties seem to be clearly split in two
when it comes to whether to stick to the
current restrictions or to allow for
gradually
gradual opening if you take angela
merkel's conservatives for example
43 percent want restrictions to stay in
place
as they are versus 52 who say that there
needs to be some careful opening and
that is of course
very close 43 versus 52's angela merkel
is in a dilemma with her own party
and the same is true for the social
democrats the greens the left party
followers
but then you've got the far-right afd
and the business-friendly fdp
party where the picture is a completely
different one where there is an
overwhelming desire to open up or open
up gradually and that is
of course not surprising because the fdp
is the party for germany's
middle stand for hotel owners etc where
many firms are struggling to survive
absolutely and you know we're seeing
some of those struggles actually playing
out in the approval ratings
uh we mentioned earlier that approval
ratings particularly for chancellor
merkel
for her government have been falling
just 50 percent of those polled say that
they were satisfied
with the policies of merkel's coalition
49
say they were not satisfied
so nina ultimately is there a chance
that this pandemic could be ruining
angela merkel's reputation
now at the end of her political career
well yeah she's not going to stand again
as candidate for
the chancellorship because germans of
course go to the polls in september
but if you look at her approval ratings
at the beginning of the crisis
and where we are now they of course they
have somewhat gone down
if you compare it to the first wave when
they were as high as they hadn't been
for five years because she was seen as
somebody who can master crises
and that has to do now the fact that
they've gone down with the sluggish
start of the vaccination campaign here
the tug of war
with and between the 16 state leaders
and the performance of her cabinet her
health minister her
economics minister who've also had
massive slums in
their approval ratings but angela
merkel's approval ratings are still
higher than they were in the two years
leading up to the start of this crisis
so yes she's not as popular as she was
during the first wave
but 64 approval still makes her
germany's most popular politician
at the moment dw political correspondent
nina jose
reporting from berlin and dw political
correspondent simon young
talked through germany's latest steps in
combating the virus with
carl lauterbach he's an epidemiologist
and a member of parliament who has
become known as a voice
of caution is chancellor merkel
leading germany in the right direction
in this pandemic
this is a very general question and i'm
not giving
um i'm not in a position basically
to uh to provide grades for her
performance that is not what i would
like to do
i think that the decisions that we have
come upon yesterday
have a couple of very strong points for
example to show
to change the vaccination strategy
so that we have a further delay between
the first and the second vaccination so
that we can
provide more all elderly people with
first vaccination
i also believe it is correct to use the
astrazeneca
vaccination for the elderly and also
believes that it is correct to use a
test
national testing strategy an
evidence-based
national testing strategy to let's say
work against a third wave which we are
currently
encountering but a general position
about what she has
what merkel has done and not what we
currently do is basically a
common performance by the governors of
the states and
the federal government and even
parliament
the chancellor talks about an emergency
break if infections go
back up you don't believe in the
emergency brake i believe in the
emergency brake
once we are up to let's say an incidence
rate of 100
per 100 000 inhabitants per week
we will come back to the lockdown that
we currently have
so that is the emergency break and i do
not only believe that this is an
emergency break i also believe we will
have to use it
right you've tweeted uh that the
strategy will cost us a lot of covid
cases and it won't help the economy
aren't you being too pessimistic
i don't think i'm too pessimistic what's
going to happen we will have
increasing case numbers because we are
in a third wave and the decisions from
yesterday
will not help to curtail the third wave
and at the same time we will not be able
to help the economy because we cannot
open restaurants or bars or anything
because when there is an
increase in caseload such openings will
not happen
so you agree with the bavarian leader
marco cerda who says that
our hearts tell us to open up but common
sense says
be cautious don't people need to have a
perspective
of how lockdown is going to end i do
think we have a perspective so
perspective is here vaccination
for everyone who is prepared to get
vaccinated to speed up the vaccination
project and we have come
up with important decisions with respect
to that
yesterday very important decisions and
to use
entity and testing self-testing as a
bridge technology so that is a
perspective
right the strategy is based on
testing as you say are there enough
tests self-tests and quick tests
available
in germany at least we do know that
enough tests could
be produced in germany we now make have
to make sure we cannot
allow a mistake here we have to make
sure that the tests that
can be produced in germany will be
produced and will also be used in
germany so that is very important
you've made a name as a critic of
rapid easing in this pandemic and
a warning voice what do you think is the
most important thing that the government
should do
going forward we should make it very
clear that a third wave is not a minor
problem that this is not a small wave
before everyone gets the vaccination
but we in order to let's see if the risk
groups vaccinated
have another couple of months to go that
is a very long stretch
in order to go through a third wave
so we have to be very very careful to
provide the testing strategy and you
also have to make the population aware
that further lockdowns despite the fact
that everyone hates them may be
necessary
can you predict when lockdowns will
finally end in germany
i think that lockdowns will end in
germany once we have let's say
vaccinated the majority of the
population professor lutebeck thank you
very much
you